president Trump is finishing a short but
significant trip to Poland this morning
he praised the country's president and
called for the world to confront North
Korea's nuclear threat then the
president spoke to the Polish people
praising how they kept their culture and
warning about threats to Western society
and both sides of the Atlantic our
citizens are confronted by yet another
danger one firmly within our control
this danger is invisible to some but
familiar to the poles the steady creep
of government bureaucracy that drains
the vitality and wealth of the people
the West became great not because of
paperwork and regulations but because
people were allowed to chase their
dreams and pursue their destinies the
president just wrapped up his speech and
is now heading to Hamburg Germany to
meet with world leaders at the g20
summit major Garrett is in Warsaw with
what the president had to say major good
morning good morning the president said
Poland is an example of courage in the
face of oppression he specifically
praised Poland's historic but ultimately
unsuccessful resistance to Nazi
occupation and its persistent efforts
throughout the Cold War to undermine
Soviet dominance here and throughout
Europe in his speech mr. Trump also
hailed Poland is one of the few NATO
nations that annually meets its defense
spending obligations and by the way he
praised it for buying billions of
dollars of us-made weapons the president
also criticized Russia's invasion of
Crimea in Ukraine and backing regimes in
Syria and Iran earlier mr. Trump met
with the Polish president on Jay Duda
whose government has been criticized in
some quarters of Europe for limiting
press freedom and judicial independence
on North Korea the president said he is
considering quote very severe things in
response to the test of an
intercontinental ballistic missile that
is technology that could reach the u.s.
with a nuclear weapon and ahead of
tomorrow's first meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin mr. Trump said
Russia and other unnamed countries
meddled in the 2016 presidential
election in the end the president said
quote nobody really knows this
of the cyber intrusions even though at
the highest levels of the US
intelligence community they have
concluded Moscow was to blame and in a
nation where press freedoms are in flux
the president eagerly criticized the US
media and former President Obama
American presidents traveling abroad
typically uphold American values such as
press freedom and the institution of the
presidency mr. Trump for his own reasons
did not Jeff major thank you very much